A blood work shows red blood cells are lower near anemia.
Is the solution to take iron supplement or are there other ways to treat anemia that
is with the rife machine?
The good news is that two weeks on the nightly rife by white blood cell count went from 143
to 118, or in the past it was rapidly trending upwards since this person has a blood cancer
and they have elevated white blood cell count, so everybody here knows that your white blood cell
count should be about 4 to 6.5, so this elevated white blood cell count is a blood cancer.
So what do you do with red blood cells that are low?
So you have an anemia, you have low red blood cells, probably elevated MCV, MCHC,
RDW, so you have other signs of anemia plus low red blood cell count.
Can you take iron for that?
So it partly depends upon the cancer and it partly depends on how anemic a person is.
If you're just near anemia but you're still within normal range,
if somebody has a solid tumor cancer, I would say no, let's be careful not to give iron.
By solid tumor cancer, I mean like breast cancer, liver cancer, colon cancer,
not a leukemia or multiple myeloma. So the leukemia is multiple myeloma and even sub lymphomas,
you could readily use iron. The reason why I say that is if you have a
a solid tumor cancer like breast cancer, colon cancer, prostate cancer, etc.,
giving iron to that, even in the case of a person having anemia, if you give iron, iron
can actually feed the cancer. That doesn't typically take place, almost never takes place with
the blood cancer, so the leukemia is an lymphoma. Typically you don't have to worry so much about that
at all and you could treat the anemia with iron. But I would want to see your labs because just because
you have low red blood cells, doesn't mean that it's necessarily iron deficiency anemia. It could
be B12 anemia, it could be B6 anemia, it could be folate anemia. There's multiple different types
of anemia in you. You discover that by looking at the other values. So the RDW, MCV, MCHC,
and some other things you want to look at in the CBC. So that's what we'd want to look
to really see, should we give this person iron? Because there's some rules in my book at least,
you could have low red blood cells, oh, I have dear anemia, but your ferritid is super high,
that you never give iron to somebody who's got high ferritid. So we'd want to look at the rest of
the blood work before we'd say, oh, you have anemia, let's low red blood cells, dear anemia,
let's just assume it's iron deficiency anemia and let's just assume that you're okay to take it because
your ferritid is normal. We need to look at that in the more specific, but that's a great question.